Tate versus Jake Paul yeah what do you
think happens
are they actually gonna fight they had a
Face-Off I think if they don't it is
even for somebody that has as many
resources as both of those guys do
they're dropping the bag big time if
they don't do it surely I mean there's
got to be name me a bigger fight that
could happen that would draw more Normal
public attention Than Jake Paul fighting
Andrew Tate
bigger fight uh Jay Paul vs Canelo
Alvarez that would be bigger I think in
order for the fight to be Big Jake needs
to be the heel
that's a [ __ ] interesting question
yeah that's the interesting question
yeah what sort of world have we got
ourselves into where Jake Paul's the
hero in a face down like only only if
you find like a guy from the the depths
of like the Ninth Circle yeah and drag
him out and here's Andrew Tate as the
bad guy yeah
it's crazy like are we supporting Jake
Paul and I don't know if he will I mean
I'm just I just know from me like I
think actually this could be an
absolutely amazing fight and Jake might
have gotten too good for this to be a
successful but Jake Paul vs Nate Diaz to
me was always the ultimate one and I
think Jake has actually gotten
too much respect for that to be as
interesting like I think most people go
into that fight going oh I think Jake
will beat up Nate Diaz really before
there was like there's no chance but we
also said that about Anderson Silva we
said that about time we said about all
these people we're gonna have to accept
that Jake is a really [ __ ] good boxer
so but I think the best fight is Jake
against a qualified MMA guy that people
love and Jake is the heel and he's doing
what he does best which is troll
antagonize I mean did we not did we not
see McGregor versus uh Mayweather as an
absolute super fight that's two heels
yeah and it was really interesting that
like Mayweather almost became a face and
he didn't know what to do yeah but would
you not love that fight would you not
love to see what happens when like an
immovable object meets an Unstoppable
Force at the press conference I'm very
Pro take take Paul like massively make
money off of it I want them to make
money I just don't know why Tate would
do it but again I don't have an idea of
his finances like if if you told me Jake
if you told me tate is worth 200 million
dollars I would say no there's no reason
to do this at all like to risk permanent
damage he's he's already said he has
like some cornea issues or eye issues
like this isn't going to be [ __ ] good
for you I think he's maybe 34 35
something like that yeah it's it's not
if you have a hundred million you
couldn't get me to do [ __ ] with 100
million 100 million bro just in bed
I'm not fighting
for a hundred million no like I don't
know why you would do that because now
what are you doing it for you're doing
it to prove
something to the public I guess you you
know went back and forth with him but
Jake is a legit [ __ ] boxer man like
this guy's dedicated his life to it and
he was young younger when he got into it
he's not one of these like 40 year old
guys that does the celebrity boxing the
kid was in his early 20s and then
dedicated every [ __ ] second to every
day to it so
yeah I don't know if I'm Tate if I would
do that I wouldn't do that if I'm tape
because you got the money why risk it
and then I suppose one of the risks for
this is every single time that Jake Paul
steps into the ring with somebody he can
only win if he gets beaten he goes look
it was [ __ ] Anderson Silva Tyron
Woodley it was whoever they are
disillustrious it's Canelo Alvarez it's
j it's [ __ ] Andrew take right you
know four-time kickboxing world champion
every single person that steps in must
have like ass splitting nerves about if
this guy [ __ ] knocks me out I'm an
embarrassment correct how can you be the
top G it's not very tab G to lose to
Jake Paul
maybe it doesn't happen you've made me
think that it doesn't happen I would
never do it if I'm Andrew tape because
the reality is Jake Paul is probably
going to beat you and that's not saying
that you're not an incredible fighter
clearly he's a [ __ ] kickboxing world
champion like one of the best kickboxers
of his time there's no doubt right we
know that for a fact
you probably haven't kickboxed him years
if you've done any training at all you
know that the instincts not just the
muscles atrophy the instincts do the
timing does like you take a year off the
time he's not there
this guy Jake has been in the [ __ ]
ring now granted he's big I mean how
tall is Andrew six two probably Oh I
thought he was taller okay
they're about the same height yeah I
wouldn't do it if I'm Andrew especially
if you got 100 Mil in the bank that's
there's no way yeah
Legacy counts for a lot man but then
press some 14 year olds on the internet
yeah I was Adam and he was gonna all
right so who does Jake fight next do you
think Nate Diaz Nate Diaz that's the one
that you would make
if you were the [ __ ] King maker Nate
Diaz because you want to Rattle up the
MMA crap you want everybody in MMA MMA
is bigger than boxing right now so it's
like you want everybody in MMA to be
rooting for the MMA guy because you have
to tap into like a stream that's bigger
than you if you really want to make
things big it can't be just your
following my following we have to
discuss an issue that all these other
people also feel and ideally they don't
even know the [ __ ] we are but they tap
into our conference you want tribalism
you want in-group out group you want
them and us
bare minimum tribal curiosity yep so
like when we put out I imagine you're
gonna put out clips from this podcast
every one of those clips is going to tap
into an issue not you not me maybe a
couple clips of a Schultz about this but
it would be about a topic that's bigger
than the both of us and ideally people
who don't even know the [ __ ] we are find
us they find you they go I like the way
this guy talks in interviews maybe I'll
listen to his other stuff yeah we're
tapping into something bigger right like
so what's the umbrella that's what I'm
looking at when I look at a fight with
them I'm like okay what's the umbrella
the MMA crowd is desperately trying to
prove that they're as qualified Strikers
as boxers the boxers are desperately
trying to prove that boxing is a much
better martial arts is a much better
form of defense and you have those two
groups using Jake and whoever he's
fighting as proxies yes do you know what
I mean it's like the war in Ukraine
right it's like Afghanistan you don't
really want the fight the fight ain't
about the Taliban versus whatever it's
about United States versus Russia
that's what I want the boxing match to
be so that and I want you know the
whoever's boxing to make the most
[ __ ] money possible it's a horrible
way to make a living so I hope Jake
makes [ __ ] tens of millions of
dollars and then retires
soon he was talking about he's already
getting some was it speech slurring or
maybe something was up with his thoughts
that's what he was saying bro can you I
mean what time how old is he now like 26
not even dude okay so let's say let's
say that Jake Paul's 26 25 26 and he's
been doing this full-time five years
four years something like that that's
quick and in the space of that long is
seeing
neurodegeneration he's speech is
changing something up with his eyes
[ __ ] wild yeah yep and that's what
I'm saying the kid is committed yeah
he's because you're putting not only
your health but literally your lifespan
on the line as well like Jake is 100
lost
maybe months maybe years from the amount
of time he's going to be alive because
he wants to pursue this purpose sport at
the moment yeah [ __ ] insane that's
who you're dealing with yes think about
someone that's prepared to kill
themselves sooner yeah you're dealing
with that level commitment are you that
committed you got 100 million in the
bank you got private jets you're the top
G you got all these girls you got
Bugattis you got everything you're
dealing with the kid who's willing to
give it all away you have it all he's
trying to get to top G if he has it I
don't know how much money is I'm
assuming he has that much money I'm
never taking that you got to be crazy
I mean I give him a lot of respect for
doing it because if he honors martial
arts that much or something whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] but no [ __ ] way uh
no at that point that kid's hungry
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]